here with reaction former White House
press secretary Sean Spicer really CNN
really your reaction well look I think
it was very gracious for the president
the first lady to open up the White
House the people's house to so many
people are the Armed Services numbers of
guests and folks for this Christmas
season to see the people's house it's
the first lady and her team just did a
marvelous job decorating at the videos
out there for all to see and and what I
think is interesting Sean and for people
who don't understand traditionally at
least in the last several years from
what I understand invitations were given
to two bureaus and they were allowed to
fight you know X number of people to the
White House Christmas party and a lot of
times those were distributed to
television and media executives and
on-air talent what the White House did
this year was really go through a
arduous process of trying to make sure
that the people who worked in the White
House media core the technicians the
sound people the lighting individuals
the people who go to the White House day
in and day out to work on behalf of
these media organizations without the
glamour and glitz of being an executive
or on-air talent got invited and got to
bring a spouse or a partner or a son or
a daughter and what CNN's decision to do
make sure that these individuals who
really probably look forward to going
can't go anymore and you've got an
individual is a ssin like Politico
that's out there surveying people on
whether or not they'll take a picture
with the president and yet some of that
same organization has reporters asking
the White House if they can get invited
or bring a guest and so it is these
media types CNN and Politico that are
doing a disservice to the gracious act
that the president the first lady have
have offered so many of these
individuals not just the on-air talent
and the executives but those technicians
that really work hard and labor on
behalf of those organizations to get the
news in the broadcast out I don't know
how you put up with their crap for all
the time that you were press secretary
be honest you have you know the patience
a job I remember one year I said to Fox
I said well was i invited and they
laughed and they said no you weren't
invited I didn't take it personally by
the way I used to joke about it well
again I think that it
always you know the way that people are
viewing this one now is very myopically
it's always through the lens of Trump
not through the context of you know what
how what happened during the Obama years
but again I'll go back to the fact that
this White House under President Trump
and First Lady Melania Trump have
reached out and graciously tried to to
make the White House the people's house
and the decorations I've never done
think that's great but something that
these people can come and share with
their family and friends because so many
of these individuals really do work hard
behind the scenes and aren't there for
their family and they get to bring them
for the first time and it's a shame that
they won't be able to participate
because Siena's executives have done
this I appreciate